let's go next to jamie in south dakota
jamie you're on the air what's going on
hello david uh can you hear me okay yes
i can
okay
um i'm like kind of like a capitalist in
like the nordic kind of model sense okay
and i know you're from um argentina and
i was just wondering if you uh followed
like any of like the leftist uh
wins in like latin america
yes to some degree i followed them did
you have a specific question about one
um i had a i was wondering if you'd
think like with their some of their talk
of like over like uh taking over like
the market economy
if uh like you think that they could
like
turn kind of like that like this
government would be different
than like the previous outcomes which
gov which government are you talking
about what country
um i don't know just kind of maybe like
chile specifically i don't know you're
saying if chile could overthrow
capitalism
or like to er like he's talking about
like uh doing different things to like
get
um make it more kind of public and like
more like more socialist and get rid of
like the market-based stuff yeah listen
i mean
i think that'd be positive countries
should do
whatever
the people want their elected
representatives to do
i'm not a socialist personally so i
wouldn't be advocating for a country to
become a socialist country
but if chile or whoever
if there's demand for it from the people
and it's not being imposed in an
authoritarian way by a you know
authoritarian of some kind
try it abs absolutely why not
right right yeah i'm just really
interested to see how it goes i'm not a
socialist personally but yeah i mean
listen give give it a go if that's what
the people want
right exactly yeah well thank you for
taking my call my pleasure you too jamie
from south dakota
uh great to hear from you